hello darkness my old friend  [Music]  [Music]  like that there are other kinds of  trolls our ancestors created six strings  each for a different type of music  [Music]  techno  [Music]  country and rock I'm gonna unite the six  strings and destroy all music except the  wrong so I'm gonna need your string we  have to unite all the trolls and if we  don't stop her who will we're gonna need  a battle plan  and weapons violence never solves a  problem is this some kind of jewel it  was actually kind of cool looking the  only weapons we need all right this guy  this guy her hugs this is gonna take a  lot of hugs this is a terrible idea that  will blow up in your face the country  trolls look friendly does anyone else  think this is crazy  oh look I think I can see our house from  up here tiny diamond is my name come  straight from my daddy's name my whole  body's makeup glitter I'll throw in your  face piece of no honey and daddy  you